la parole est à notre collègue laurent
duplomb pour le groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
madame la première ministre après mon
rapport sénatorial de 2019 qui alertait
déjà sur le déclin de la production
agricole française favorise en même
temps l'entrée toujours plus grande de
produits agricoles importés qui ne
respectent pas nos normes après
l'épisode de koh vide qui nous a fait
prendre conscience de notre dépendance à
des produits faits à l'autre bout du
monde est dans le même temps nous à
faire recoudre découvrir l'intérêt
majeur d'une alimentation produite en
france après l'entrée en guerre de la
russie contre l'ukraine faisant flambée
des prix jamais égalés les matières
premières à l'école ce qui nous rappelle
l'intérêt majeur de disposer d'une
agriculture forte et protégés après nous
avoir fait croire que vous aviez
récemment compris tout cela en nous
vantant par exemple les bienfaits des
clauses miroir en rebaptisant le
ministère de l'agriculture en ministère
de la souveraineté alimentaire
comment en ayant dit et vu tout cela
pouvez-vous ne pas vous opposé aux
accords de libre échange entre l'union
européenne et la nouvelle zélande
pour vous répondre
la parole est aux milices de l'europe et
des affaires étrangères
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur du plomb la
commission européenne est parvenue en
effet dans le cadre de ses compétences
en matière commerciale à conclure le 30
juin un accord de commerce avec la
nouvelle zélande nous sommes en train de
l'évaluer en détail mais en première
analyse je souhaite vous dire qu'il
s'agit d'un bon accord et je vais vous
dire pourquoi
d'abord parce qu'il va faciliter l'accès
au marché néo zélandais et renforcer nos
positions dans nos secteurs exportateurs
en matière de biens comme de services
ainsi que notre accès au marché public
néo-zélandais
ensuite parce qu'il s'agit de l'accord
le plus ambitieux en matière de
développement durable que l'union
européenne ait jamais conclues sur le
modèle qui nous conduit désormais à
intégrer des clauses environnementales
et sociales dans les accords de nouvelle
génération je ne doute pas que vous y
soyez sensible sur le sénateur il
prévoit des sanctions commerciales en
particulier en cas de violation des
principaux engagements en la matière et
enfin c'est un bon accord parce qu'ils
protègent n'offre nos filières agricoles
sensible et parce qu'il soutiendra nos
exportations agricoles et
agroalimentaires notamment en protégeant
plus de 200 indications géographiques
comme le compte et au le jambon de
bayonne par exemple et ceci n'est pas
anecdotique pour nos territoires loin de
là
cet accord sera signé et ratifié par
l'union européenne dans le cadre de ses
compétences également après approbation
du parlement européen avec olivier bayle
je m'engage évidemment à venir vous le
présenter plus en détail une fois que
cette approbation aura été acquise je
vous remercie monsieur du plomb
j'en appelle à un sursaut national
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça madame la
première ministre que je vous avais posé
la question et que j'aurai véritablement
espérer que vous y répondiez
arrêtons tant qu'il est encore temps
ces injonctions contradictoires nous ne
pouvons pas rajouter sans cesse des
critiques des contraintes des normes qui
tue la compétitivité de notre
agriculture et la livre et en même temps
à une concurrence déloyale
vous ne pouvez pas continuer d'interdire
de plus en plus de molécules en france
et fermé les yeux sur les produits issus
d'une agriculture néo zélandaise qui
utilisent encore de l'atrazine interdite
chez nous depuis 2003 madame la première
ministre
madame la première ministre réveillez
vous il aurait mieux valu que vous
répondez à la question plutôt que votre
ministre car la france agricole se mord
entre sécheresse abandon des surfaces
cultivées des capitalisations des
troupeaux partout en france si vous
n'arrêtez pas le massacre vous
connaîtrez le même sort qu'avec
l'électricité le black out alimentaire
alors quand comprendrez-vous enfin la
leçon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]